Before looking at additional actions, though, I would like to
see what is the basic workflow in a version control system
using the three actions that we just saw. And to
do that I'm going to use two of our friends, Brad
and Janet. So we have Janet here, Brad, and a
VCS that they are using. Now imagine that Janet creates a
file called foo.txt and puts some information in the file.
At that point she might want to add the file to
the repository and to commit it so that her changes
and the file get to the central repository. And when she
adds and commit, that's exactly what will happen, in foo
will be come available here, and will be accessible to the
other users. In this case it'll be accessible to Brad.
If Brett were to run an update command, what will happen
is that the file foo.txt will be copied on the local
work space of Brad and Brad will be able to access
the file. At this point Brad might want to modify
the file, for example add something to this existing file.
After doing that, he also may want to share the
updated file with Janet. To do that, he will commit the
file and the result will be exactly the same of
when Janet committed her file. That the updated file will
be sent to the repository and the repository will store
that information and make it available for other users. So now,
if Janet performs an update, she will get the
new version of foo.txt with the additional information that was
added by Brad. And we will see all of this
in action in our next demo in a few minutes.